we were filming in Atlanta right now
it's going very well it's going very
well and every day there are shots there
are images that are pairing of
characters you've never seen before on
screen that again I'm very lucky to do
what I do I'm very thankful to do what I
do and I do it because I keek out for
these everybody is charlie we finally
found out another movie that Marvel is
developing for phase 4 news sites are
reporting that they're making a Captain
Britain movie which I know people have
been asking for for a while which a
totally quirky character really awesome
Alan Moore run so you have to imagine a
Marvel superhero based on the King
Arthur myth written by Alan Moore
they're supposed to be moving on it
later this year so I'll explain what all
that news is but if you're new to the
channel we're doing a new round of that
spider-man ps4 giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video so the actual
news comes from somebody that works at
Pinewood Studios that says that Marvel
has booked studio space later this year
to cast for Captain Britain so this is
what he said
I work at various movie studios in the
UK and I've been situated at Pinewood
for a few weeks and I'm moving to
Cardiff on a project soon I haven't seen
anything about this online anywhere so I
thought that I'd send the info to you
space at Pinewood has been booked for
November in December 2018 to hold
auditions for a Marvel project called
Captain Britain in the Black Knight the
name of the director booked for all
these dates is Guy Ritchie Marvel seems
to be moving fast with it to fill the
space left behind by Danny Boyle's
aborted bond 25 everyone's excited
because it looks like another few months
of solid work when we thought that we
would have to wait for a while Kevin
Feige said they were doing some really
weird stuff in Avengers 4 setting the
stage for an even broader Marvel
Cinematic Universe meaning more
international superheroes Black Panther
was just the beginning of that of course
they'd get to Captain Britain one of the
premier UK superheroes in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe another cut so I just
love to say as Captain Britain is that
one that does it have been discussed
about things we have discussed it we
have discussed that there are a lot of
actors that come in and ask about that
about that part we'll talk about Captain
Britain's history in the comics a little
bit because there are a couple support
characters that are popping up Jessica
drew spider-woman is a bit of a
crossover character with a Captain
Britain comics and she's rumored to be
appearing during spider-man far from
home we're getting ready for another
Doctor Strange movie in the next couple
of years in Morgan la Fey is another
Captain Britain character one of the
most powerful magic characters in the
Marvel Universe so it seems like a
pretty easy slam-dunk really awesome
British director with a uniquely comic
book II looking movie style who can do
really good action so just seems like an
easy win for a superhero movie inside
the Marvel Universe with an Alan Moore
story based in present day the real
problem with this though this November
December date for them casting people is
the fact that people working on Robert
Downey jr. and Jude Law's Sherlock three
said that they were gonna try and start
shooting later this year and Guy Ritchie
is directing that movie so this seems
like a bit of a conflict what I think
ended up happening is is because you
have two books to do space like they say
that they booked for auditions at
Pinewood Studios because bond left you
have to do that really really far in
advance so even if you don't know
whether or not a movie is actually gonna
get made you still have to pay a pretty
big fee to book that studio space in
case you're gonna make a movie what
probably ended up happening is is that
about a year and a half ago when that
King Arthur and the legend of the sword
movie started bombing Guy Ritchie was
like I need to find another project
because Warner Brothers is probably
never gonna hire me to direct another
movie again it was a really expensive
flop but Guy Ritchie given the right
material and a good script can make a
good movie Kevin Feige probably saw this
as an opportunity hey you know what
somebody just pitched me Captain Britain
you know we'll be cool Guy Ritchie maybe
that'd be good opportunity so they
probably met on the project but also at
the same time because Robert Downey jr.
and Jude Law are slowly leaving the
Marvel Cinematic Universe or at least
Robert Downey jr. won't be quite as
present post Avengers 4 he suddenly has
all this free time on his hands to
devote to his other franchises like the
sherlock movie franchise and he's been
talking about doing sherlock 3 with Jude
Law for several years now but they got
so caught up with Civil War Iron Man was
a huge character during that then he
signed on for spider-man homecoming
another really big project then the
shot infinity war and Avengers for
back-to-back that's almost like an
entire years worth of filming so our DJ
has been booked solid ever since that
last Sherlock movie came out so he just
sounds like Robert Downey jr. wanted to
make Sherlock three told Guy Ritchie you
know around last year sometime and he
was like okay that seems like a pretty
easy slam-dunk the safe bet
so we'll fast track that maybe they
backburner the Captain Britain project
so it sounds like they intend on making
it at some point but they'll either wait
for Guy Ritchie to be done with Sherlock
three or they'll just find some other
really awesome British director to take
it but regardless of what these crew
people at Pinewood say I don't think
that they're going to make the Captain
Britain movie anytime soon they have too
many other big slam dunks I think it's
just one of those projects that could be
really awesome given the right script
and the right director in the right cast
so because it's not super urgent Kevin
Feige is just waiting for all those
stars to align so they can do a really
awesome version of that rather than rush
it into production when things aren't
quite right the quick rundown on his
origin story is is that his parents died
under mysterious circumstances
later he eventually joined this research
project at the dark more labs someone
tried to sabotage the project he died
pursuing the villain and was visited by
the omniverse Guardian Roma who gave him
the call to action in the opportunity to
become Captain Britain she gave him a
choice the Amulet of right or the sword
of might he didn't feel like he was much
of a warrior so he chose the amulet of
right that transforms him into Captain
Britain so he gains his powers via
amulet you have to imagine his powers is
sort of a spin on Captain America's
powers superhuman strength speed
endurance agility durability reflexes
senses but he can also create force
fields energy beams and he can fly when
they say the title is Captain Britain in
the Black Knight there are a couple
different versions of the Black Knight
there's one who was a villain then his
nephew was a good person
the whole idea being is that their
family tree descends from Sir Percy the
original black knight of the King Arthur
myth they passed something down called
the ebony blade so another magical sword
King Arthur myth of course magical
swords proliferate but it gives him a
measure of immunity to magic
so we'll be a very effective tool for
fighting someone like dr. strange or
another magic user like Morgan lepay who
is very big Marvel magical villain just
get hyped up that they're planning on
doing this sometime in the near future
it doesn't sound like it's gonna be
happening right away like there are a
couple films Kevin Feige has said that
they're definitely doing and we've
already gotten dates for some of those
like Black Panther - the Black Widow
movie who knows what's gonna happen with
guardians 3 we'll probably get a Captain
Marvel sequel we have the Eternals movie
that they announced let me know in the
comments though who would you actually
want to be Captain Britain in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like what actor do
you think that would be perfect for that
obviously it would probably have to be a
Brit
if Jude Law hadn't just done that King
Arthur in the legend of the sword movie
and he wasn't already playing Marvel in
the Captain Marvel movie I would say he
would be a pretty good pick but let me
know in the comments who do you want
that to be what happened is is I'll name
a new giveaway winner when I post new
marble leave all your requests in the
comments below
but click here to learn all about the
secret invasion storyline between
Captain Marvel and Avengers 4 and click
here for my Hawkeye video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you